er ist 74 jahre alt und wiegt über 100
kilo und damit gehört trump ganz klar
zur corona risikogruppe was das für den
gesundheitszustand des us-präsidenten
bedeuten könnte darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit mediziner dr thomas aßmann ja
guten tag herr assmann lassen sie uns
erst mal über das alter sprechen 74
jahre was könnte das für den verlauf der
krankheit bedeuten
das ist schon dramatisch weil natürlich
die altersgruppe über 60 deutlich
schwerere symptome hatten noch
todesfälle als die jüngeren patienten
und darf jetzt nur mal erinnern auch an
als szenario den präsidenten um asyl in
der ist 65 jahre alt und hat krone gab
aber unseren präsidenten beziehungsweise
premierminister aus johnson aus england
der vag 52 jahre ja beide waren jünger
als er
hatten aber doch schon starke symptome
waren boris johnson der war drei tage
auf intensivstationen und das problem
ist nicht nur wie übersteht er die
akutphase sondern ist eher nach der
erkrankung wieder anführungszeichen der
alte hatte dieselbe power demselben
einsatz wie zuvor
oder braucht er wirklich sehr lange
distanz also sprich drei vier fünf sechs
wochen um wieder zu alter form zurück zu
kehren
das natürlich für den wahlkampf ganz
entscheidend weil wir sprechen auch
nicht mehr von heilung bei kurven
sondern vom genesung wald eben teilweise
die zeit sehr lang sein kann um wieder
zur alten stärke oder zur alten form
zurück zu kommen hat er heute 105 50
jährigen patientin bei mir bist ein
komischer krank war es selber
sportwissenschaftler am
olympiastützpunkt im rheinland hier
er sagte in meiner ersten nacht mit
kogge dachte ich müsste sterben der 55
und wie gesagt dieser präsident den usa
ist 74 also es wird wirklich dramatisch
werden
also eben einfach man kann ich mir immer
wieder sagen eine krankheit die man
nicht auf die leichte schulter nehmen
sollte und kann über 100 kilo das habe
ich vorhin erwähnt welche rolle spielt
das gewicht denn bei einem
krankheitsverlauf
also dürfte es relativ einfach zu sehen
also adipositas also übergewicht ist ein
risikofaktor und zwar einfach man
vermutet ist einfach die lunge sich
nicht mehr so ideal auch mal ein ding
zusammenziehen kann wie sonst auch und
dass das einfach auch die belüftung
innerhalb der lunge behindert und auch
die arten die atmung behindert die
atmung hält muskulatur und das ist durch
er deposit asphalt eingeschränkt diese
freie atmung und deswegen ist
wahrscheinlich dass übergewicht gerade
bei google das ja auch eines der organe
angreift deswegen so negativ
auswirkungen haben könnte
jetzt sagte ramms arzt der dem
präsidenten gehe es zunächst gut wie
schnell kann so was denn kippen man
spricht hier immer wieder von diesem
ominösen elften tag an dem der
krankheitsverlauf dann doch wieder
schlimmer werden konnte wir haben das ja
auch gesehen bei boris johnson dem es
zunächst gut ging weg sagt haben sie
genau recht also den wir unser boris
johnson erinnern
der 20 jahre jünger ist als tramp da war
es so die ersten vier tage war noch ganz
gut drauf und alles gut und hatte er
noch ein video konferenzen wie die
ansprache gehalten und dann ist die
sache gekämpft
also wir müssen wenn wir jetzt eine
woche abwarten denke ich dann können wir
wirklich sagen wie sieht es aus wie
klappt das weil das ist nämlich die
kritische zeit wie weit jetzt unser
immunsystem oder sein immunsystem
reagiert und das ist das problem einfach
wie ist der tag 7 wie wird das zu gehen
weil hier die ersten tage denke ich noch
gar nicht so entscheidend sondern
entscheidend sind
während sein da sitzt du das elfte tag
und dann entscheidet sich ob köhler top
und doch entgegen
letzte frage doch dass man wie es ja
ihre einschätzungen wir es jetzt mal
zusammenfassen
über 100 kilo 74 jahre glauben sie an
einen milden verlauf oder wie hoch ist
das risiko wie schätzen sie das ein das
ist doch zu einem schweren verlauf kommt
als gedacht
also man muss ehrlich sagen das haben
damals schon recht dass es eher
glaubenssache
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
das bei uns so einfach ab geht weil er
schon schwergewichtig ist und die sache
ist eben die dass sie eben mit einer
soll man sagen eine einstellung einer
gesunden lebenseinstellung oder
positiven lebenseinstellung leider denn
wir wussten nicht überzeugen können
sie sehen wieder an bord johnson er war
sich sehr positiv eingestellt ist ja
auch sehr energiegeladen ist ja
ähnliches muster wie trump und den hat
es ja voll zerbröselt er hat der war
wirklich
wirklich schwer kranke auf
intensivstation und ich befürchte das
ist bei jump nicht so harmlos ab gehen
wird wie manche kommentatoren denken
oder auch warten und hoffen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren